sometimes you just want a Big Mac and
you should be able to have it those
businesses are preying on the community
Maryland's Prince George's County is
plagued with the highest obesity rates
in the Washington DC area higher
incidence of cancers obesity diabetes a
heavyweight battle between customer
choice and government regulation is
heating up Prince George's Councilwoman
Karen towles has a bill that would give
officials final say on what fast-food
eateries open up by requiring property
owners to go to the County Board before
changing the use of their property
addresses eating and drinking
establishments fast-food establishments
it addresses gas stations I'm here to do
what the people have hired me to do
protect them and to keep them healthy
well it's really about a social
engineering Justin Wilson of the Center
for Consumer Freedom is against the bill
which he says infringes on the freedom
of consumers and businesses at this
point the law says you have to put
notice that you're trying to create a
fast-food restaurant as if anyone in the
community is allowed to vote on what a
business owner is allowed to do with his
or her business we don't let the
community vote on who's allowed to move
into which home or which businesses are
allowed to move into other businesses
tolls however sees the fast-food
businesses as trespassers who are
preying on her constituents many of
these business owners don't even live in
a county don't even live in that
community but they are making decisions
that are affecting the community without
their input if a fast-food restaurant is
offering things that people then one eat
then that restaurant would go out of
business but Prince George's County has
the highest obesity rates in the DC area
is it because there's too much fast food
obesity is far more complicated than
just blaming it on one single industry
whether it's the soda industry of their
fast-food industry if the causes of
obesity are complicated so our
government attempts to restrain fast
food even this towles is pushing her new
law the county recently loaned three
hundred thousand dollars for Little
Caesars Pizza to open two new locations
perhaps most people are eating fast food
not because it's the only alternative
but because they like it and at the same
time we have a variety of healthy fast
food restaurants or we have a variety of
healthy things on the menus of the
fast-food restaurants that are otherwise
serving cheeseburgers and french fries
consumers deserve I think a degree of
choice and zoning is so core to
infringing
what a building owner a restaurant owner
or consumer are engaging in tolls bill
is scheduled for a vote later this year
for recent TV I'm Kennedy